We are seeing now climate impacts that
are tremendously costly in tremendously
challenging in EPA.
His role is to try to make turn that
challenge into a positive message moving
forward,
give communities the tools they need to
adapt,
you know,
recognize that the time for action is
now.
So in many ways the the problem that we
had in the past was twofold.
People didn't see the impacts as as,
as much as they're seeing them and
feeling them today.
It wasn't already.
It's happening.
What do I do?
And so we were predicting things that
might happen,
but it's taken so long to take action.
Those predictions are already here and
frankly we never predicted the kind of
impacts that we are seeing today.
Climate is always portrayed on newscasts
as being some kind of big debate.
You know,
the big debate among the scientists is
that 97 percent of them know it's
happening and I really worried about it.
Three percent are skeptical.
That's not a balance.
That's an overwhelming majority in that
needs to drive the decision,
especially in a democracy.
That's how we work.
We're working really hard with faith
leaders in this country because many of
the people listened to their faith.
Lead is for direction in the faith.
Leaders are extremely concerned that
climate change is an issue which most
importantly more significantly impacts
low income and minority communities.
The least of these are going to be the
most impacted in a changing climate,
so we are moving with with an
ecumenical,
a constituency in the faith community to
bring this message to their constituents
and it's extremely important to
recognize your own limitations about
who,
who you're good at talking to and who's
going to believe you and who the people
you're trying to influence listened to
because we can talk all we want about
the science at EPA,
but you need to put that into people's
homes and ears in a way that they're
going to listen,
absorb,
and know they can be part of the.
The solutions moving forward that gets
them off the diamond builds a
constituencies you need to succeed in
something that is really as big as this.
The challenge of climate change is
enormous for us,
and so you need to attack that from all
different angles and make sure to get
everybody engaged.
I don't need to fight the climate
deniers now.
That's not what I think we need.
The rallying cry needs to be.
What actions do we take that are going
to address climate,
both from,
you know,
we need to mitigate and make sure that
we're reducing those impacts,
but also let's do it in a way that grows
a low carbon economy.
Let's make the United States flourish
because we stood up to this problem and
we took action.